taking Iverbectin and I'm up to 120 milligrams daily. Remember that the dose for Iverbectin for cancer
would be a half a milligram per kilogram weight. So you convert your weight into kilograms,
you start at a half a milligram per kilogram of your weight, and then you could slowly titrate
up from there. The past week since I've increased the dose, I've had extra severe brain fog
and my memory is greatly impacted as well. Could these be side effects of the Iverbectin?
Should I cut back? And how slowly should I increase again? So could these be side effects of
the Iverbectin? Yes, they could be. Should you cut back? Yeah, probably. Should you go back up
again? Well, it's good. It depends on where you're at with your cancer. If your answer to that question
is, well, my cancer is pretty stable. I don't think it's growing. There's no other, there's no
subjective signs that it's growing. There's no objective signs that it's growing with different
blood tests with PET scans, with CT scans, with tumor markers. Then I wouldn't necessarily
raise my dose. Matter of fact, you might want to lower your dose. If there is subjective and or
objective signs that the cancer is going in the wrong direction that it's growing, then yes,
then maybe you slowly go back up. Cut back on your dose. See if those symptoms go away and then you
could go up slowly. So that's how I would at least approach that.